99 of them who call you they don't need
you right
mental go see a therapist go do see a
doctor etc etc okay the one percent that
does is the four signs you look for but
you haven't seen it yet right because
the four signs of unbelievable strength
speaking a different language and all
this you haven't experienced that what
is the one percent that tells you karen
we got to meet with this person because
this sounds like something's really
going on
what are some of the things you notice
with the one percent because the one
percent the initial things that i would
tell them when they first reach out to
me is
do the normal aspects of a faith life
you don't have to do anything
extraordinary
but you know are you are you going to
church are you worshiping god whatever
faith tradition you have you know the
church isn't trying to proselytize
anyone through the ministry of exorcism
if somebody is rooted in some faith
tradition the first thing i would tell
them
have you gone and spoken to your
pastor have you spoken to your rabbi
have you spoken to your imam
if so if you have a faith you know
background have you gone and explored
that with whatever faith leader that you
have
because again
i think a lot of people today and this
has been my experience they're looking
for a quick fix
they simply believe they're dealing with
the demonic they believe i have a bag of
tricks
you know i can make their problems go
away
but they don't have any skin in the game
but ultimately people need to realize
that the best defense
is to live out one's faith
it doesn't mean one has to become some
holy roller or whatever it's somebody
who believes that god
has a place
in their life that god has a role to
play
okay so
the time where the person levitated and
you saw that okay
how many pre how many sessions did it
take for this person to go back to being
normal oh nothing ever happened you know
what was the results with that
individual
father carmine would meet with people
you know sometimes people
that were dealing with the demonic it
was one session and they were free
other times it may have taken multiple
sessions
and sometimes people will then ask the
question why is it more than once jesus
commanded the demons to leave they did
so immediately
and at least in my experience it has to
do with the strength of the
demonic possession that's taking place
and that somebody has really been
forthright in telling me everything
about their situation sometimes people
are embarrassed you know it would be
like going to your doctor
and not telling your doctor everything
without that information
the doctor can't give you the right help
that you need so i always say
i'm not there to judge somebody on why
they may have opened up an entry point
to the demonic in their life but i need
to understand it so i can know how to
help them close that doorway but again
it's not just a matter of casting the
demon out god has to be invited in
luke's gospel in chapter 11 it talks
about how once the demon has been cast
out it goes and wanders through the arab
wasteland and then coming back and
finding the house swept clean
it goes and brings seven other demons
worse than itself and they take up
residence in the person being swept
clean meaning it was cast out but god
wasn't invited in
and i do see a lot of people today who
believe they're dealing with the demonic
who want the demonic to go away but they
want nothing to do with god
but what they fail to realize that in an
exorcism
jesus is not a bystander he's the main
actor
so if they're not inviting christ into
their life at that moment if they're a
christian then obviously
things aren't going to play out very
well so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
you